Trascrizione: Dania Guetti
Revisore: Sergio P
Allora dai ragazzi, cominciamo subito
con un quiz di genetica difficile.
Vediamo come ve la cavate.
In questa simpatica famiglia
(Risate)
chi è il padre biologico del bambino?
[Papà Figlio Mamma Idraulico]
Vediamo un po', chi vuole indovinare?
Idraulico? Chi vota per l'idraulico?
Chi vota per il papà?
Nessuno. Uno. Fiducioso.
L'idraulico va per la maggiore.
Strano. Ogni volta che faccio questo quiz
tutti votano per l'idraulico.
Avete fatto un esperimento di genetica.
Non vi sto prendendo in giro.
E' vero, perché avete usato le conoscenze
di genetica che sono nella nostra testa,
nella nostra cultura.
Senza sapere niente del DNA tutti noi
dall'alba dei tempi sappiamo
che esiste un'ereditarietà.
Quindi genitori e figli si somigliano
e nelle famiglie
ci sono delle somiglianze.
Non è proprio una cosa scientifica
perché poi invece se uno va a fare
un test del DNA magari
scopre risultati diversi.
Però dai, ve la siete cavata,
fatevi un applauso.
(Applausi)
Poi dopo facciamo un altro esperimento.
Questo sono io nel secolo corso,
intorno al 1995.
Ero un giovane ricercatore, come vedete
pieno di speranze
e di energia per il futuro.
Non ero bello ma
non ero neanche bruttissimo.
Il dramma di noi biologi molecolari
era che eravamo infrequentabili.
Eravamo considerati dei super nerd.
La cosa che noi studiavamo, cioè il DNA,
veniva vista come roba da laboratorio,
da camici bianchi.
Ogni tanto capitava di andare
magari ad una festa,
arrivava una ragazza
con il bicchiere in mano,
ti chiedeva "Beh tu di cosa ti occupi?"
Appena pronunciavi la parola DNA
girava i tacchi e spariva.
Eravamo veramente considerati
dei topi di laboratorio.
Adesso le cose sono cambiate.
Intanto voi siete qui, siete in tanti
e, fra le altre cose,
siete venuti anche
a sentir parlare di DNA.
Non potete scappare perché le uscite
di sicurezza sono state bloccate
in questa occasione.
Però è successa nel frattempo qualcosa
che ha reso il DNA una cosa molto diversa.
È successo questo.
[Dovrebbe sputare in questo tubo]
[Lo riempia di saliva
fino alla lineetta nera]
[E' un bel po' di saliva]
[Questo era bello.
No ragazzi ce ne vuole tantissima]
[Sto per rivelarvi i risultati
del mio test del DNA]
[Il test del DNA è un regalo
dei miei genitori]
[Fra qualche settimana avrò i risultati]
[il mio DNA sarà online]
[e c'è anche una specie di social network]
[Io sono Roxy e sono troppo emozionata]
[perché ho i risultati
del mio test del DNA]
[Sono entrata nel mio account
e i risultati stavano là]
I risultati stavano là.
Cosa succede?
Migliaia, centinaia, milioni oggi
di persone che vanno su internet,
acquistano una lettura online del loro DNA
e poi non solo
una volta che hanno il risultato
vanno su Youtube...
Persone di tutti i tipi: studenti,
giovani, vecchi di tutto il mondo
e su Youtube, su Facebook, sui social
raccontano la loro esperienza.
Il DNA non solo diventa qualcosa
che è uscito dai laboratori
ed è entrato nelle nostre case.
È diventato qualcosa
che ha un contenuto social.
Adesso vedremo anche di cosa si tratta.
Il DNA da cosa di topi di laboratorio
è diventata una cosa figa.
Devo dire che anche la mia vita sociale,
un pochino, ci ha guadagnato.
(Risate)
Poco!
(Applausi)
Come funziona?
Si va su Internet,
esistono ormai decine, dozzine di siti
che offrono questi servizi,
si va su Internet, con la carta di credito
si acquista un kit che ti arriva a casa.
Una scatolina come questa, un bel gadget.
Dentro questo kit c'è uno
di questi provettoni
che avete visto nel filmato,
ci si sputa dentro.
Pensate, un viaggio così tecnologico
inizia con uno sputo, con la cosa
più semplice del mondo.
Si spedisce lo sputo al laboratorio
dove viene estratto il DNA
e viene analizzato, decodificato.
L'ho fatto anche io,
sono anch'io uno sputatore.
Dopo un paio di settimane mi arriva
un'email che mi dice
"Caro Sergio,
il tuo profilo genetico è pronto.
Con la tua username e la tua password
accedi al sito, alla tua pagina
e inizia a navigare nel tuo DNA."
Proprio così.
"Navigare nel tuo DNA."
Io non l'avevo mai fatto.
Una cosa che succede al mio sputo
e quindi al mio DNA durante questo viaggio
è qualcosa di straordinario
che non ha precedenti nella storia.
È il cuore di quello che vi racconto oggi.
Il mio DNA viene decodificato
con delle tecniche che ovviamente adesso
non vi sto a raccontare,
e le sue componenti chimiche,
che sono delle lettere chiamate
basi nucleotidiche,
ce ne sono quattro A G C T e ne abbiamo
3.2 miliardi nel nostro genoma,
quindi nel nostro DNA, vengono lette,
decodificate e trasformate in un file.
Questo passaggio è fondamentale.
Il contenuto delle nostre cellule,
del nostro organismo,
si duplica in una forma extracorporea.
Da questo momento in poi, io non ho
solo il DNA che sta dentro al mio corpo
ma ne ho una versione digitale,
extracorporea che può fare il viaggio
di tutti i file che noi usiamo in rete.
Può andare su Internet,
può entrare in un social network,
può essere duplicato
e condiviso all'infinito.
Questo è un passaggio davvero epocale.
Per esempio, io vado in giro con questa
chiavetta usb dove dentro c'è un file
con il mio DNA.
L'ho scaricato dal sito,
perché si può fare.
È un file che contiene il mio profilo
genetico, praticamente la versione
digitale del mio DNA.
Cosa posso fare con questo file?
Beh, posso fare delle cose che
prima erano impossibili.
Una cosa è questa.
Questo è il Facebook del mio DNA.
Qualche anno fa ho scritto un libro
che si intitola "Il DNA incontra Facebook"
dove parlavo proprio dell'alba
della genomica digitale
e dei social network genomici
e qualche libraio mi ha detto che il libro
veniva messo nel reparto fantascienza,
perché evidentemente pensavano
che fosse qualcosa di molto futuribile.
Io ho insistito naturalmente sul fatto
che questa cosa esisteva davvero
e il Facebook del mio DNA è proprio qui
in questa diapositiva.
Questa funzione si chiama Trovaparenti
e fa esattamente quello che dice il nome.
Il mio file di DNA viene confrontato
con il file DNA di tutti gli altri clienti
del sito e là dove emerge una parentela
fino al quinto grado,
quindi fino al cugino di quinto grado,
fra i nostri DNA il sistema me lo segnala.
Adesso ho questa bacheca dove, vedete,
nella prima colonna ci sono profili
di persone con foto, a volte, nome,
cognome, informazione che io naturalmente
ho oscurato per tutelare la loro privacy.
Nella seconda colonna il Trova Parenti
mi dice qual è il grado di parentela
che io ho con queste persone.
Nel mio caso ho trovato dei cugini
fra il terzo e il quinto grado.
Quindi lontani cugini
che stanno in giro per il mondo.
L'ultima colonna, a parte quella di mezzo
dove ci sono dati particolari,
è la più interessante perché è il tastino
per chiedere l'amicizia.
Proprio come su Facebook posso chiedere
l'amicizia a queste persone.
Loro lo fanno con me, naturalmente
l'ho fatto anche io, e adesso
ho qualche dozzina di parenti,
lontani cugini sparsi per il mondo
con cui non avrei mai avuto
nessun contatto se non fosse stato
per il confronto dei nostri DNA.
Questo, come potete capire, è un vero
e proprio social network,
ha tutte le caratteristiche.
L'unica cosa però che accomuna gli utenti
è il fatto di avere qualche affinità
nel DNA. È un social network
basato sui nostri geni.
Qui, se guardate, c'è un piccolo numero,
non si vede forse da lontano.
Adesso ho più di 800 parenti,
cugini sparsi per il mondo.
Adesso di più perché la slide è vecchia,
1100, 1200 cugini in giro per il mondo.
Io dico cugini, però se io fossi
l'idraulico della prima slide e magari
avessi qualche figlio sparso
in giro per il mondo o magari fossi stato
un donatore di sperma, può succedere,
potrebbe capitare che un bel giorno
uno di questi messaggi dica "Caro papà,
sono tuo figlio e voglio conoscerti."
Anche questo non è fantascienza,
è una cosa che succede
in questi social network.
Tant'è che moltissimi ragazzi
che sono stati adottati o sono nati
in provetta usano in modo massiccio
questi strumenti per trovare
i loro genitori biologici.
Un'altra cosa che posso fare
con il mio file è andare a ricercare
le mie origini genealogiche.
Come una scatola nera, in qualche modo
nel mio DNA c'è scritta la storia
del mio lignaggio.
Quando vado indietro nelle generazioni,
come vedete, scopro che fino ai trisnonni
posso fare risalire la loro origine
all'Italia. Poi quando vado indietro
nel tempo succede quello che ci si aspetta
e cioè che le mie origini si sparpagliano
in giro per il mondo.
Più andiamo indietro e più
le nostre origini ovviamente
sono mescolate.
Questa è una cosa che sembra ovvia,
è evidente, io la riassumo dicendo
che sono un bastardo genetico,
e lo dico con orgoglio.
Nel senso che sono un miscuglio
di tutte le etnie, di tutte le popolazioni
del mondo, come tutti voi.
Qualcuno ancora questa lezione
non l'ha capita,
con dei risultati esilaranti.
Questo signore che vedete nella foto
si chiama Craig Paul Cobb
ed è un razzista americano.
È il leader di una formazione
di suprematisti bianchi, quelli che dicono
che i bianchi sono superiori, esisitono
le razze umane, eccetera eccetera.
Questo signore ha avuto l'ottima idea
di andare a legger il suo DNA
però ha avuto la pessima idea
di farlo in televisione.
Questo è il risultato.
[Craig Paul Cobb si è sottoposto
al test del DNA]
[per determinare le origini genetiche.]
[Lei è europeo per l'86%]
[... e per il 14% africano!]
[Cobb: Un attimo, un attimo...]
[Cobb: Questo si chiama rumore statistico]
[Tesoro, significa che sei un po' nero,
ecco.]
(Applausi)
Un applauso alla figuraccia di questo
povero signore, che se avesse studiato
un po' di genetica saprebbe benissimo
che la nostra specie, Homo Sapiens,
nasce centomila anni fa in Africa,
e quindi tutti noi,
anche voi se fate questo test,
scoprite naturalmente di avere
un po' di DNA africano
nei vostri cromosomi.
Scoprite anche voi di essere
dei piccoli bastardi genetici,
cosa di cui dovete andare orgogliosi.
Questi strumenti sono
una bellissima dimostrazione,
che possiamo toccare tutti con mano
a casa nostra,
di quello che i genetisti ripetono da anni
cioè non esistono le razze umane
e ci raccontano una lezione che forse
in questi tempi vale la pena di ricordare.
(Applausi)
Grazie. Ricordiamocelo.
Basta parlare di DNA e parliamo di vino.
Vi piace il vino?
Che vini preferite? Cabernet?
Un bel Amarone della Valpolicella?
Perché c'è anche un'applicazione
su Internet che vi trova il vino adatto
in base al vostro DNA.
(Risate)
Voi dite: "Beh lo faccio o non lo faccio?"
Non c'è bisogno.
L'esperimento lo facciamo adesso
tutti insieme, gratis, quindi vi faccio
risparmiare qualche soldo.
Avete nella vostra bag una scatolina.
Lo so, nella bag c'è un sacco di roba
ma dovreste avere una scatolina
come questa, dove c'è scritto "Taste me".
Dietro c'è scritto "Aspetta lo speaker
giusto per aprire questa scatola."
Sono io lo speaker giusto.
Pronti?
Attenzione, aprite la scatolina
con attenzione perché trovate
una caramella, che sembra una caramella
ma in realtà è l'antidoto all'esperimento,
e una strisciolina di carta, questa.
Io non la vedo ma voi sicuramente
nel grande schermo la vedete.
Allora, pronti?
Pronti per l'esperimento?
Bisogna prendere questa cartina.
Cercate di produrre un po' di saliva
che funziona meglio l'esperimento.
Producete saliva e poi, non ingoiatela,
mettetela in bocca come se fosse
una caramella, assaggiatela con il fondo
della lingua preferibilmente.
Uno, due, tre...
Vedo già qualche faccia schifata.
Sta facendo effetto sul vostro corpo,
sul vostro organismo.
Attenzione, alzi la mano chi ha sentito
il sapore della carta.
Ok.
Alzi la mano chi ha sentito
un sapore amaro.
Ok.
Alzi la mano chi ha sentito un sapore
amarissimo, schifoso.
Perfetto. Fatevi un applauso
perché anche questa volta
l'esperimento ha funzionato.
Adesso vi spiego in cosa consiste.
Il mondo si divide in gustatori
e non gustatori.
Quelli che non sentono il sapore
sono naturalmente non gustatori
e quelli che sentono l'amaro
sono gustatori.
Poi ci sono i supergustatori
che lo sentono ancora più forte.
Questo dipende da un gene.
Esiste un gene che abbiamo tutti
e che però esiste in diverse versioni.
Alcune versioni permettono di sentire
questo sapore amaro, altre invece
sono neutre e non permettono
di sentire il sapore.
Questo sito che vi ho detto
fa esattamente questo,
legge il vostro DNA e capisce se avete
questa versione del gene o meno.
Io infatti non ho assaggiato la cartina
come avete fatto voi
perché so già che sento questo sapore
amaro molto forte
perché ho letto il mio DNA
e c'è scritto che sono un gustatore.
Sembra una stupidata ma in realtà
ci dimostra qualcosa di importante
che esiste anche una genetica
delle preferenze e in questo caso
delle preferenze alimentari.
Immaginatevi di sederci tutti insieme
ad una bella tavolata
in un ristorante stellato.
Ordiniamo lo stesso menù,
stiamo mangiando la stessa cosa
ma in realtà non stiamo mangiando
la stessa cosa
perché ognuno di noi sentirà dei sapori
diversi in base al profilo genetico.
Faremo un test del DNA prima di andare
al ristorante, può darsi, chi lo sa,
di sicuro c'è qualcosa di nuovo
che prima non sapevamo.
Visto che parliamo di cibo
volevo concludere con qualcosa
veramente di speciale che ho portato qui
e che riguarda il nostro DNA.
Ho voluto portarvi quella che è
la dimostrazione e la forma più bella,
lampante, di quello che è il nostro DNA.
Attenzione...
(Risate)
L'ho dovuta portare con molta attenzione.
Ecco.
Ok.
La vedete sul grande schermo?
Un biscotto.
Il biscotto siamo noi
e il DNA è la ricetta del biscotto.
Perché parlo di una ricetta?
Perché quello che ci hanno insegnato
a scuola sul DNA è questo.
Il libro della vita, il progetto
per la costruzione dell'organismo.
L'enciclopedia degli esseri viventi.
Sono tutte immagini molto suggestive
che però rimandano a qualcosa
di molto deterministico.
Il progetto di questo teatro è identico
alla versione finale,
cioè quella che vediamo adesso.
Non c'è differenza tra il progetto
e il prodotto finale.
La ricetta è una cosa molto diversa.
La ricetta è un insieme di ingredienti
che si mescolano in modo caotico,
interagiscono tra di loro,
interagiscono con l'ambiente esterno
e alla fine viene fuori un prodotto
che noi possiamo prevedere in parte.
Se io leggo la ricetta di questo biscotto
so che verrà un cookie al cioccolato.
Però non posso essere davvero sicuro
di quello che verrà nel dettaglio.
Io prendo questi due biscotti.
Sono nati dallo stesso impasto,
hanno lo stesso DNA,
sono cotti nello stesso forno.
Se fossero due persone
sarebbero due gemelli identici.
Proprio come due gemelli identici
non sono esattamente uguali.
Io li vedo da vicino e mi rendo conto
che ci sono delle piccole differenze.
Chiunque conosca dei gemelli identici sa
che anche che i gemelli identici
non sono davvero identici.
Questo perché quando andiamo a vedere
il DNA di una persona in realtà
stiamo leggendo una ricetta.
Molte cose si posson capire da una ricetta
ma non possiamo avere la certezza
del prodotto finale.
Questo è molto importante perché ci dice
una cosa che dobbiamo ricordarci.
È un messaggio che vorrei lasciarvi
per portarvelo a casa.
Il DNA non è destino.
Molte cose che riguardano oggi
la genetica ci portano a credere,
a pensare, che tutto quello che siamo
è scritto nel nostro DNA.
Non è vero.
Proprio come in una ricetta, se il mio DNA
venisse trovato qui su questo palco
potrebbero scoprire molte cose su di me
ma per esempio non potrebbero
misurare la mia intelligenza o capire
se sono predisposto alla matematica,
o ad un certo tipo di comportamento,
perché sono caratteristiche complesse
che dipendono solo in parte dai geni
e molto dall'ambiente in cui viviamo,
dal forno in cui cresciamo.
Questo significa una cosa molto semplice,
che se il nostro DNA è una ricetta
e non è destino noi siamo molto più liberi
di quello che pensiamo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)